I have triangle ABC here and in the last
video we started to explore some of the
properties of points that are on angle
bisectors and now what I want to do in
this video is to see what happens when
we apply some of those ideas to
triangles or the angles and triangles
so let's bisect this angle right over
here angle BAC and let me draw an angle
bisector so the angle bisector might
look something I want to make sure I get
that angle right into pretty close so
that looks pretty close so that's the
angle bisector let me call this point
right over here I don't know I could
call this I could call this point D and
then let me draw another angle bisector
the one that bisects angle a BC so let
me just draw this one looks it might
look something like that right over
there and I could maybe call this point
e so ad bisects angle BAC and B e
bisects angle ABC so the fact that this
green line ad bisects this angle right
over here that tells us that this angle
must be equal to that angle right over
there they must have the same measures
and the fact that this bisects this
angle angle ABC tells us that the
measure of this angle angle a be e must
be equal to the measure of angle e BC e
BC now we see clearly that they have
intersected at a point inside of the
triangle right over there so let's call
that point let me call it I just for fun
I'm skipping a few letters but it'll be
it's it's a useful letter that based on
what we are going to call this in very
short order and there's some interesting
things we know about I I sits on both of
these angle bisectors and we saw in the
previous video that any point that sits
on an angle bisector is equidistant from
the two sides of that angle so for
example I sits on a D so it's going to
be equidistant from the two sides of
angle BAC so this is one side right over
here
this is one side right over there and
then this is the other side right over
there so because I sits on a D we know
that these two distances are going to be
the same assuming this is
this is the shortest distance between I
and the sides and we also show in that
previous video that when we talk about
the distance between a point and a line
we're talking about the shortest
distance which is the distance you get
if you drop a perpendicular so that's
why I drew the perpendiculars right over
there and we could even let's label
these some this could be point F this
could be point G right over here so
because I sits on ad sits on this angle
bisector we know that I F we know that I
F is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to I G
fair enough now I also sits on this
angle bisector it also sits on B II
which says that it must be equidistant
from a the distance to a B must be the
same as eyes distance to BC eyes
distance to a B we already just said is
this right over here it's IG but we also
know that that distance must be the same
as the distance between I and BC so if I
draw if I drop another perpendicular
right over here and let's say I call
this point let's see I haven't used H
right over here this distance must be
the same as this distance because I sits
on this bisector so IG must be equal to
IH IG must be equal to I age but I F is
also equal to IG so we can also say that
I F I mean if I F is equal to I G is
equal to IH we also know that if' I F is
equal to IH pretty much common sense if
this is equal to that that is equal to
that then these two have to be equal to
each other but if I is equidistant from
two sides of an angle this is the second
part of what we proved in the previous
video if you have a point that is
equidistant from two sides of an angle
then that point must sit on the angle
bisector for that angle so we this right
here tells us tells us that I must be on
angle bisector I is on angle bisector
angle bisector sector of angle a see
because it's equidistant to the two
sides of angle a
çb and what we've just shown is is that
there's a unique point inside the
triangle that sits on all three angle
bisectors it's not always obvious that
if you took three lines in fact normally
if you took three lines they're not
going to intersect in one point two
lines very reasonable thing to do but
three lines not always going to
intersect in one point but once again
like we saw with the circumcenter where
we took the perpendicular bisectors of
the side that was pretty neat that they
intersected in one point now it's also
cool that we're showing that the angle
bisectors all intersect in one unique
point eyes on the angle bisector of ACB
so the angle the bisector of ACB will
look something like this will look
something like this and this angle right
over here is going to be congruent to
this angle right over there so we've
just shown that if you draw it if you
take the three angle bisectors of a
triangle it will intersect in a unique
point right over there that sits on all
three of them so it seems worthwhile
that we should call this something
special and we do and that's why I
called it I we call I the in Center the
in Center the in center of triangle ABC
a BC and you're going to see the second
why it's called the in-center
when we talked about the circumcenter
that was the center of a circle that was
that could be circumscribed about the
triangle I will see in about five
seconds is the center of a circle that
could be that is circumcised that can be
put inside the triangle that's tangent
to the three sides and how do we
construct that well we've just
established that I is equidistant to
each of the sides that this length is
equal to that length is equal to that
length so what happens if you set up a
circle with I as a center that has a
radius equal to the distance between I
and any one of the sides which is equal
that has the radius that has a radius
equal to I f IG or I H well then you're
going to have a circle that looks
something like you're going to have a
circle that looks something like this
you're going to let me draw it a little
bit better than that I don't have really
well you can imagine this is my best
attempt to draw a circle this circle
right here that has the radius equal to
the distance between
in any of the sides which we've already
established as being equal we see that
it's sitting inside of the circle so why
don't we call this an incircle so circle
I remember you label circles usually
with the point at the center circle I is
the in circle in circle of triangle ABC
and of course the radius of circle I so
we could call call this length R you say
R is equal to i F which is equal to I H
which is equal to IG is equal to IG we
can call that length the in radius and
it makes sense because it's inside when
we had when we were talking about the
intersection of the perpendicular
bisectors we had our circumcenter
because that was the center of a circle
that is circumscribed about the triangle
now we're taking the intersection of the
angle bisectors and then using that
we're able to define a circle that is
kind of within the triangle and that
whose sides are tangent to the circle
and since it's inside it we call this an
in circle we call that intersection of
the angle bisectors the in center and we
call this distance right over here the
in radius